[Musique]
tu vois de l'autre ses tissages plein
c'est pour la réunion aux parents
d'élèves
je pourrais jamais y être a peut-être
est-on baby sitter peut y aller un self
on notera ça se mange temps - m bonjour
bonjour monsieur canova j'imagine
marguet je porte mon amherdt accord
gigabarre bienvenue claj en suisse ont
peur de remédier des parents qui fait
l'annoncé ce lundi matin et le nom de
l'association des parents d'élèves c'est
obligatoire
voilà je pense que j'ai tout vu c'est
pour ma fille mais rien parce que là on
est sur une suspicion de troubles
alimentaires
elle mange que du mou en ce moment cru
d'humour vous avez détesté je peux aller
faire pipi
est ce que tu peux attendre pardon
pardon qui est disponible au le vendredi
saint vincent
je peux rien moi je fais pas piscine pas
de sortie parce qu un bon je vous
préviens le premier qui fait une
réflexion sur mon moule [ __ ] je dois 65
/ 16 ans je pense à servir à jamais hop
pièce un rendez vous individuels avec la
maîtresse oui c'est pour rencontrer les
parents et parler de ses ventes est
atteint
42 bizarre de vous voir dans la vraie
vie ce qui fait normal et émile cool
limites
[Applaudissements]
bellemare son bénéfice de la coopérative
ou bien téléphoner cuiseur dit julien
crotte mais j'adore l'odeur
aujourd'hui vous êtes insultant
alors elle est comment cette maîtresse
que non compétent toi bon
[Musique]
on parle
flash spécial le mont paix que tout est
entré en éruption sont addicts
explosivité et de huit secondes de trois
chambres restantes pour exploser les
unes après les autres
une explosion nucléaire peut diminuer la
pression de la chambre
[Musique]
vous êtes en train de me dire que vous
comptez faire sauter une bombe nucléaire
la frontière chinoise
capitaine son temps d'honorer les têtes
nucléaires rejoignez le dit que doit
avoir lieu l'explosion séparation de la
tête diffèrent
j'ai lancé le compte à rebours
je te donne rendez-vous en enfer
le volcan va entrer en action
mon gouvernement ne cautionnera pas
cette mission
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe moi j'arrive pas
à le croire
ouais tu entendu ça c'est strange non
ouah c'est une mouche mais nous aussi
[ __ ] c'est une mouche et pour quoi on
sert pas de la mouche la poursuivre dosé
pour l'adresse comme un singe qu'on peut
envoyer tu vois dans une banque pour
nous ramener le pognon de la banque et
nous on fait rien on l'apprivoisé des
livraisons et c'est fou de se voir c'est
quoi ce courant attendu comme le second
dias toi je pouvais pas je suis pas
cautionner une qui me prend pour un
autre mec fait tourner le truc hockey ou
quoi les arrêtés pour combien de temps
les crados le savoir j'ai préparé des
paupiettes de dad
elle a eu un choc au cerveau entre un
accident de ski et depuis ben et parle
comme ça quoi bon appétit à tous laissez
vous dans cette jambe ont fermé comme ça
je peux rien je regarde pas mais
poitrine wii dont se revendre à traquer
crayola histoire dont c'est le monde qui
est détraqué equal les gens pètent les
plombs
wow ça craint alors là c'était quoi ce
gros machin une mouche une mouche ouais
[Musique]
prévert dont je suis
la plage
la hauteur
[Musique]
hélas
c'est ça
je sais ça
[Musique]
c
vous allez me dire que je peux pas voir
mon crise qu'en dire à cause d'un papier
vous avez commencé vos démarches en
israël vous devez les comptines et en
scène raconte ça va être comme si
j'étais jamais parti ok
je te promets
[Musique]
m
c'est là que j'ai compris que
[Musique]
comme les autres
contre nous ça allait durer
danica may nicoletta commun et coteaux
de moi
[Musique]
moi moi et cherche un médecin des mamans
et montréal d'être chaud
un quine au moins
manon comco économies et on essaie de
positionner si séguinaud cumulant des
temps
[Musique]
la caméra de joe cole ou du monde au
canada
il m'a dit on mérite
le cachet année non non non on a le chic
de mitraillettes ont cogné petit
[Musique]
famille disparue frontières ne pâtissent
pas l'assiette
[Musique]
m
au petit jour
[Musique]
wen jiabao
écoutant ma mère
et
covidien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas ce que c'était mais en tout
cas y'a plus rien je vous jure y avait
des poils j'avais fumé ou paca mais non
non non c'est sûr on appris des
champions avec ma copine monde en prend
souvent mais tournons pas que tu aies eu
des poils sur la lame et que tu les as
he has et tu te met à hurler à la lune
ou à te transformer en loup garou qui
pourra revenir me voir c'est drôle ça
mais non je plaisante
les médecins m'ont a de l'humour quand
même 12 8
[Musique]
maintenant c'est bien mais c'est pas
trop tôt c'est pas faux
pour qu'il passe la main
tous les jours
[Musique]
sayah
faut aimer la nuit où les yeux car c'est
toujours
[Musique]
abl
avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]